हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल। तो सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे
रही है तो जल्दी से चैट में बता दीजिए।
प्लीज जल्दी से चैट में बता दीजिए। सबको
मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है?
ओके तो वेरी गुड। तो चलो ठीक है स्टूडेंट
आ रहे हैं धीरे-धीरे। तो जो क्लास 83 थी
तो सबको समझ में आई थी।
क्लास 83 में मैंने जो भी कुछ आपको बताया
था सबने प्रैक्टिस किया।
सबने प्रैक्टिस किया।
क्या किसी ने प्रैक्टिस किया?
किसी ने भी प्रैक्टिस किया यहां पे?
मुझे तो नहीं लगता कि किसी ने प्रैक्टिस
किया होगा।
क्या कोई बता सकता है कि लास्ट टाइम जो
एरर फेस कर रहे थे मैंने तो सॉल्व कर
लिया। मुझे मुझे पता चल गया कि वो एरर
क्या थी जिसकी वजह से हम अपनी मशीन पर
डाटा एक्स फिल्ट्रेट नहीं कर पा रहे थे।
फिर भी मैं जानना चाहता हूं कि कोई ऐसा है
क्लास में जिसने वो चीज सॉल्व करने की
कोशिश की है।
मैंने आपको साथ कोड शेयर नहीं किया था
ग्रुप में क्योंकि मैं चाहता था कि आप
स्क्रीन से देखो उसको खुद से समझ के
कोशिश करो लिखने की।
ओके? तो फिर भी आज की क्लास में आगे बढ़ने
से पहले मैं आपको एक चीज बता देता हूं। आज
की क्लास का ड्यूरेशन ज्यादा लंबा नहीं
रहने वाला है। फिर भी मुझे लगता है कि वह
एक घंटा खींच जाएगा। तो लेकिन मैं आपके आज
की क्लास से रिलेटेड आपको एक कुछ
इंपॉर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन यह बताना चाहूंगा
कि आज की जो क्लास है वो बाकी क्लास से
थोड़ी सी हटकर है। थोड़ी सी एडवांस है और
हो सकता है कि कुछ चीजें इसमें आपको समझ
में ना आए। हो सकता है कि आपके ऊपर से जाए
वह चीजें। हो सकता है वह चीजें आपके ऊपर
से जाए। तो इसीलिए मेरी रिक्वेस्ट है कि
आज की क्लास को सीरियस तो लीजिए बट समझने
के लिए क्योंकि अभी आप उस लेवल पर नहीं
होंगे ताकि आप उसको समझ पाए। हां अगर आप
ग्रेजुएट हो या मास्टर्स कर रहे हो देन
डेफिनेटली आप उसको समझ पाओगे। अदरवाइज आप
उसको आपको यह क्लास समझने में थोड़ी
डिफिकल्टी होगी। तो बस मैं आपको दिखाना
चाहता था चाहता हूं इस क्लास के जरिए कि
हम और कितना एडवांस इसमें आगे बढ़ सकते
हैं। अपनी स्टिल्थ लेवल को कैसे धीरे-धीरे
बढ़ा सकते हैं हिट एंड ट्रायल की हेल्प
से। तो यह हिट एंड ट्रायल का जो स्टिल
टेक्निक टू है इस पर मैं आया हूं क्योंकि
स्टिल टेक्निक वन हमारी जो टेक्निक इससे
जब सबसे फर्स्ट हमने क्लास ली थी तो उससे
तो बेटर है ये कि स्टिल टेक्निक वन और
टेक्निक टू उससे ज्यादा बेटर है क्योंकि
आज हम क्या करने वाले हैं https के थ्रू
हम डेटा एक्स फिल्ट्रेट करेंगे तो इट इज ए
न्यू फॉर एवरीवन जहां पर पython का यूज
होने वाला है और जहां पर जिसजिस को यहां
पर पython की नॉलेज होगी उसको वह पython
वाला कोड समझ में आ जाएगा। तो मैं उसको कट
कॉपी पेस्ट ही करने वाला हूं ज्यादातर
कोड्स को क्योंकि बहुत सारे कोड्स ऐसे हैं
जो शायद आपके लिए अभी सही टाइम नहीं है
सिखाने के लिए लेकिन जस्ट फॉर
डेमोंस्ट्रेशन और अभी हमने काफी सीख लिया
वीबीए के टेक्निक्स के बारे में। तो जो
नेक्स्ट क्लास रहेगी तो हम एक्चुअल वर्क
करते हैं। नेक्स्ट क्लास भी हमारी वीबीए
के अंदर ही है। बट नेक्स्ट क्लास में हम
क्या करेंगे कि मैं आपको पहले बता देता
हूं कि जो नेक्स्ट क्लास में हम सीखने
वाले हैं हमारा जो एमएसएफ पेलोड्स होते
हैं जो मेटासइड के जो पेलोड्स होते हैं
उनको हम इसके अंदर कैसे एग्जीक्यूट करवा
सकते हैं। कैसे वीबीए कोड के अंदर
इंटीग्रेट करके हमारा रिवर्स सेल ले सकते
हैं। अभी तक हमने डेटा एक्सिल्ट्रेशन
किया। एनुमरेशन किया है। एनुमरेशन और डाटा
एक्सिल्ट्रेशन काफी हो गया। बहुत हो गया।
अब हम नेक्स्ट क्लास से हम कहां कहां काम
करेंगे? हम काम करेंगे रिवर्स सेल पर कि
हमें रिवर्स सेल कैसे लेना है। तो रिवर्स
सेल कैसे लेना है? दूसरा हम सीखेंगे कि जो
पावर सेल के पेलोड्स हैं उनको कैसे ड्रॉप
किया जाता है। तो कुछ अच्छी-अच्छी चीजें
हम सीखने वाले हैं आने वाली कुछ और
क्लासेस में। तो प्लीज क्लास को छोड़कर मत
जाना। अदरवाइज मेरा कुछ जाएगा नहीं और
आपका बहुत कुछ चला जाएगा। तो चलिए फिर हम
प्रैक्टिकली चलते हैं। तो प्रैक्टिकली
चलने के लिए हमारे पास क्या है? हमें एक
नया वर्ड डॉक्यूमेंट ओपन करना पड़ेगा।
क्योंकि पहले मैं जो प्रीवियस कोड था उसको
रन करके दिखाऊंगा। तो उसको रन करने के लिए
मुझे क्या करना पड़ेगा? मुझे अपने वर्चुअल
मशीन पर जाना पड़ेगा। उसके लिए तो उसके
लिए तो हम वर्चुअल मशीन पर ही हमें जाना
पड़ेगा। तो कोई बात नहीं हम कट कॉपी पेस्ट
कर लेंगे वर्चुअल मशीन पर जाने के लिए। तो
अभी मैं सिंपल क्या करने वाला हूं?
डायरेक्ट
बिल्कुल
सॉरी सॉरी मैं इसको यूज़ नहीं करने वाला।
इसको मैं क्लोज कर देता हूं। और आप लोगों
के लिए मैं जाता हूं इसके अंदर
डॉक्यूमेंट्स के अंदर एंड डॉक्यूमेंट्स के
अंदर मुझे ये रहा डेमो के लिए। इसको मैं
ओपन करता हूं। ठीक है? मैंने इसको ओपन
किया है। अभी हम इसमें कोड इंसर्ट करने
वाले हैं। ठीक है? तो डेवलपर में जाएंगे
विजुअल बेसिक्स और दिस डॉक्यूमेंट
अब इसको कंट्रोल ऑल करके मैं क्या कर देता
हूं डिलीट कर देता हूं और अभी मैं आपको
स्टेप बाय स्टेप कट कॉपी पेस्ट करके
दिखाने वाला हूं वो कोड क्योंकि जो लास्ट
क्लास में हमें हमसे एरर हुई थी वो भी मैं
आपको बता दूंगा वो एरर हमारी कहां पर थी
और हमें कहां पर क्या चीज मिलेगी तो चलो
सबसे पहले हम क्या करने वाले हैं ये हमारा
कोड इस पूरे कोड को हम क्या करते हैं
स्टेप बाय स्टेप हम कट कॉपी पेस्ट करने
वाले हैं। तो सबसे पहले इतना कोड हमने
कॉपी किया और हम चलते हैं किसके ऊपर? इसके
ऊपर और यहां पर हम कर देते हैं पेस्ट। ठीक
है? तो ये चीज आपको क्लियर है? सबसे पहले
कमेंट है। हमारी जो पहली मिस्टेक थी वो थी
ग्लोबल वेरिएबल डिक्लेरेशन में। जो हम
ग्लोबल वेरिएबल डिक्लेअर कर रहे थे। वो
कहां पर डिक्लेअर कर रहे थे? हम इसके नीचे
डिक्लेअ कर रहे थे। जो फंक्शन था ना हमारा
डॉक्यूमेंट ओपन और ऑटो डॉक्यूमेंट ओपन तो
हम इसके नीचे यहां पर डिक्लेअ कर रहे
जिसकी वजह से एक एरर आ रही थी कि जो आपका
वेरिएबल आप एंड जो सब है जो सब रूटीन है
इसके नीचे आप वेरिएबल डिक्लेअर नहीं कर
सकते। तो इसी वजह से उस एरर को हम इस यहां
से रिमूव कर लिया। तो अब ये एरर नहीं
आएगी। तो पहला कोड आपको क्लियर होगा। यहां
तक क्लियर है ये कोड आपको? चलो नेक्स्ट हम
क्या करने वाले हैं? हमारा मेन रिकॉर्न
इंजन या मेन रिकॉर्न फंक्शनंस है। उसको हम
क्या करने वाले हैं? एंड कट कॉपी पेस्ट
करने वाले हैं जो मैं आपको क्या करने वाला
हूं अभी आपको समझा दूंगा। ठीक है? कंट्रोल
सी एंड गुड ओके तो यहां पर हम क्या कर
देंगे? पेस्ट हमने इसको पेस्ट कर दिया।
पूरे के पूरे को सॉरी कंट्रोल जेड फिर से
वही सेम पेस्ट हो गया।
कॉपी
नेक्स्ट पेस्ट हमने पेस्ट कर लिया। तो अभी
मैं आपको बता देता हूं। तो यहां तक आपको
क्लियर होगा। यहां तक आपको क्लियर है। अभी
हमारा क्या है? मेन रिकॉन
फंक्शन।
मेन रिकॉर्ड फंक्शन। ठीक है? नेक्स्ट इसका
नाम रखा हमने रन स्टिल रिकॉर्न फंक्शन।
ठीक है? यहां पर देखिए अभी हम ऑब्जेक्ट
सेल नेटवर्क विन सर्विस कॉल आइटम्स
ऑब्जेक्ट आइटम्स अटैक अटैकर आईपी अटैकर
पोर्ट पीएस एक्स फिल्ट्रेट और एस्केप
रिपोर्ट ये सारे हमने क्या कर लिए यहां पर
वेरिएबल डिक्लेअर कर लिए वेरिएबल डिक्लेअर
करने के बाद आपको सबको पता है कि हम क्या
करने वाले हैं फिर एक डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट
सेल के लिए ऑब्जेक्ट क्रिएट किया एक हमने
नेटवर्क के लिए ऑब्जेक्ट क्रिएट किया उसके
बाद हमने किसके साथ ऑब्जेक्ट क्रिएट किया
गेट ऑब्जेक्ट किसके किसके लिए आपको बताया
था मैंने एक डेटाबेस होता है जहां पर आप
सारी डब्ल्यूएमआई की जो कॉम ऑब्जेक्ट के
थ्रू आप क्या कर सकते हो डब्ल्यूएमआई के
साथ डायरेक्टली इंटैक्ट कर सकते हो मेमोरी
के अंदर और आप अपनी इनेशन गैदर कर सकते हो
तो ये वो वाली लोकेशन है इसका भी एक
ऑब्जेक्ट क्रिएट कर लिया उसके बाद यहां पर
मैं लिख देता हूं
डेटा एक्स फिल्ट्रेशन
फिल्ट्रेशन फिल्ट्रेशन
इन
ए वेरिएबल
एक वेरिएबल हम डेटा एक्सल्टेशन कर रहे
हैं। देन यहां पर एक वेरिएबल रिपोर्ट डेटा
क्योंकि वो ऊपर डिक्लेअ कर दिया था।
एंप्टी है। उसके बाद आप देखोगे ये कुछ
हेडर्स मैंने यहां मेंशन किया है। ये सेम
आपको पता होगा। देन सबसे पहली कमेंट
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की डिटेल फैच करने के लिए
हमने क्या किया? एक क्वरी यूज़ करेंगे।
सेलेक्ट ऑल विन ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम। विन 32
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम। ऑलरेडी लास्ट क्लास में
मैं अच्छे से इसको पढ़ा चुका हूं। देन उसके
बाद हमने फॉर लूप का यूज़ किया। नेक्स्ट
नेटवर्क कॉन्फ़िगरेशन डिटेल्स फाइंड आउट
करने के लिए इसका यूज़ करते हैं हम। ये
रहा। ओके। नेक्स्ट यहां पर देखोगे। उसके
बाद थर्ड वन हमने क्या किया? लोकल यूजर
अकाउंट डिटेल्स। इसका यूज़ कर रहे हैं हम।
wmआई सर्विस डॉट एग्जीक्यूट क्वरी सेलेक्ट
ऑल फ्रॉम विन 32
यूजर अकाउंट व्हाइल लोकल अकाउंट इक्वल टू
ट्रू। उसके बाद हमने नेम, एसआईडी, लोकल
अकाउंट, डिसेबल, लॉकउ, पासवर्ड
रिक्वायर्ड, पासवर्ड चेंज, पासवर्ड
एक्सपायर, डिस्क्रिप्शन इतनी सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन हम कलेक्ट कर रहे हैं। उसके
बाद हमने एक रजिस्ट्री का चेक भी इसके
अंदर लगाया है। तो यहां पर अगर आपको समझ
में नहीं आया तो मैं इसको थोड़ा सा अलग कर
देता हूं और इसके बाद शायद समझ में आ रहा
होगा। लो। तो यहां पर एक रजिस्ट्री चेक
हमने लगाया है। सिक्योरिटी रजिस्ट्री चेक
पर्सिस्टेंट चेक करने के लिए। मतलब कि
मुझे क्या करना है कि अगर अपनी
पर्सिस्टेंट एक्सेस मेंटेन करना है तो
उसके लिए मुझे एक ऐसी जगह चाहिए जहां पर
मैं क्या करूं जैसे सिस्टम ऑन हो वहां पर
मेरा पेलोड एग्जीक्यूट हो तो मुझे ऐसी
रजिस्ट्री के अंदर ऐसी बाइनरीज ऐसी सर्विज
के बारे में इंफॉर्मेशनेशन चाहिए तो ये
देखिए यहां पर हम ये कर रहे हैं उसके रन
कीज़ ये उसका पाथ है आपको पता है कि जो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] एचकेम सॉफ्टवेयर
Microsoft Windows करंट वर्जन रन यहां पर
आपको क्या मिलती है जहां पर ऑटो रंस वाली
रजिस्ट्री कॉन्फ़िगर मिलती है। ऑटो रंस
वाले प्रोग्राम्स कॉन्फ़िगर होते हैं। कोई
स्क्रिप्ट, पावर सेल कुछ भी मिल सकता है।
तो, यहां पर यह किया हमने। ओके, परफेक्ट।
उसके बाद टारगेट नेटवर्क कॉन्फ़िगरेशन यहां
और यहां पर हम क्या कर रहे हैं? अभी अटैकर
आईपी में अपने किसका आईपी दे रहे हैं हम?
काली Linux आईपी
काली Linux आईपी लिसनर पोर्ट में 44 44
उसके बाद हमने क्या किया यहां पे? एस एस
के सिंगल कोड यहां पर क्या कर रहे हैं हम?
यहां पर हमने क्या बताया था ना मैंने कि
अगर मेरे वेरिएबल में जो आउटपुट स्टोर हुआ
है जो टेक्स्ट है टेक्स्ट में कहीं पर भी
अगर सिंगल कोट होगा उसकी वजह से क्या हो
सकता है कि जो पावर सेल की जो कमांड है वो
ब्रेक हो सकती है उसमें एरर हो आ सकती है
वो क्रैश हो सकती है उसको बचाने के लिए
मैंने क्या किया यहां पर रिप्लेस फंक्शन
का यूज़ किया ये हमारा एक्चुअल पेलोड था ये
हमारा एक्चुअल पेलोड था ठीक है ये हमारा
एक्चुअल पेलोड था ओके उसके बाद हमने
एग्जीक्यूशन किया उसके बाद क्लीन अप कर तो
यहां तक सबको क्लियर है? कोई डाउट है?
यहां तक किसी को कोई डाउट है?
और अगर आप लोगों को
हमारी जो स्लाइड है जो हमने पीपीटीज बनाई
थी पीपीटीज हमने अपने जो हमारा टेलीग्राम
ग्रुप है उसमें शेयर की थी और वहां पर
आपको एक चार से पांच या छ से आठ पीपीटी
एक्स्ट्रा उसमें शेयर की गई थी। अगर आपने
उनको ओपन करके देखा होगा। जहां पर मैंने
क्या किया था इसी कोड का जो डिफेंसिव एन
एनालिसिस है मतलब जब ये कोड रन हुआ उसकी
वजह से कौन-कौन से इवेंट जनरेट हुए उसको
काफी गहराई से मैंने उस पीपीटी में मेंशन
किया हुआ है। अगर किसी ने पढ़ा होगा तो
आपको आईडिया होगा। अगर नहीं पढ़ा है प्लीज
उस पीपीटी को ओपन कीजिए। पीडीएफ में जो
मैंने आपको प्रोवाइड की है और लास्ट के
कुछ छह या सात सात स्लाइड्स हैं। वहां पर
जाके आप क्या कर सकते हो? उनको पढ़ सकते
हो जिससे आपको पूरा आईडिया हो जाएगा कि
डिफेंसिव साइड में ये क्या-क्या जनरेट
करती है। कैसे प्रीवियस जो हमारी
स्क्रिप्ट थी उससे कैसे थोड़ी सी स्टिल
है। ये स्टिल्थ नंबर टेक्निक वन की बात हो
रही है अभी तक तो वो आपको पढ़ना चाहिए और
अगर आपको किसी को यहां पर नहीं पता है कि
हमारा एक टेलीग्राम चैनल है सॉरी
टेलीग्राम ग्रुप है जहां पर हम क्या करते
हैं? अपने आइडियाज शेयर करते हैं। जहां पर
हम अपने नोट्स शेयर करते हैं, रिसोर्सेज
शेयर करते हैं। तो इसको कैसे रन करना है
इसके बाद करते हैं। तो चलो हम एक काम करते
हैं अभी एंड चलते हैं हमारे वीएम वर्क
स्टेशन पर। तो वर्क स्टेशन तो भैया अभी
बंद पड़ गया होगा। तो चलो फिर हम ऑन करते
हैं।
ओके। हमारा ऑन है। नेक्स्ट अभी हमें
Windows 10 को भी ऑन करते हैं। क्योंकि
हमें प्रैक्टिकल एग्जीक्यूशन देखना है ना
भाई।
तो प्रैक्टिकल एग्जीक्यूशन तो हमें ऐसे ही
मिलेगा।
लास्ट टाइम प्रैक्टिकल एग्जीक्यूशन मैं
आपको शो नहीं कर पाया था। बट इस टाइम 100%
मैं आपके सामने प्रैक्टिकल एग्जीक्यूशन शो
करने वाला हूं।
ओके। ओके ये हमारी Windows मशीन ओपन हो गई
है। तो इसको हम अभी क्या इधर से बंद कर
देते हैं। कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। और अभी
यहां पर हमें क्या करना? डॉक्यूमेंट लेटर
आना है। तो डॉक्यूमेंट को हम क्या करते
हैं? अभी सेव कर देते हैं।
ये रहा ये डॉक्यूमेंट सेव कर देते हैं।
सबसे पहले इसको मैं क्या कर देता हूं?
सेव।
कंट्रोल s तो जैसे इसको मैं डॉक्यूमेंट को
सेव करता हूं और मैं क्लोज कर देता हूं।
इसको सेव किया मैंने और इसको क्लोज कर
दिया। और ये डॉक्यूमेंट मेरा कहां पर है?
ये डॉक्यूमेंट मेरा यहां पर है। ठीक है?
और इस डॉक्यूमेंट को मैं क्या करता हूं?
कॉपी करता हूं या डॉक्यूमेंट ड्रैग करता
हूं। यहां पर ले आता हूं। ले आया। यह
डॉक्यूमेंट यहां पर आ गया। अब उसके लिए
मुझे क्या करना है? पहले कालीक्स पर एक
लिसनर ऑन करना पड़ेगा। चलो भैया सबसे पहले
मैं चेक कर लेता हूं। यहां पर कुछ है तो
नहीं। तो यहां पर अभी रिकॉर्ड रिपोर्ट.xt
steelth.txt है। तो एक काम करते हैं। हम
इनको डिलीट कर देते हैं। तो रिमूव स्टिल्थ
txt सबको दिखाई दे रहा होगा। चलो कर दिया
हमने अगर यहां रिकंफर्म कर लेते हैं। अब
इसके बाद करते हैं हम नेटक कैट लिसनर
थोड़ा सा थोड़ा सा इशू होगा क्योंकि अब
मशीन हैंग करेगी। ये रहा अभी मैं ये ये रन
करूंगा। netclist में hfन l hfन पोर्ट और
फोर और फोर tth डॉटxt ऐसी कोई फाइल हमारे
पास अभी तक नहीं है। तो इसको मैं क्या कर
देता हूं आगे नेक्स्ट अब चलते हैं हम फिर
किसके ऊपर? Window 10 के ऊपर और इस फाइल
को हम क्या करते हैं? राइट क्लिक ओपन करते
हैं। राइट क्लिक एंड ओपन किया। ओपन करते
ही यहां पर आपके सामने ये आया। मैं यहां
पर करता हूं इनेबल कंटेंट। जैसे मैंने
इसमें इनेबल कंटेंट किया तो यहां पर देखिए
ध्यान से।
इट विल वर्क और नॉट। लेट्स सी। तो यहां पर
ओके वो कोड काम किया नहीं किया हम देखते
हैं। और उसके अलावा यहां पर देखिए यहां पर
कुछ हुआ। हो गया। हमारा काम हो गया इनेबल
कंटेंट करते ही। देखो अगर देखोगे कैट
सिलthxt
यह देखो रिकॉर्न हो गया इनेबल कंटेंट करते
ही रिकॉर्न हो गया अभी देखो प्लीज इसको
मैं शेयर नहीं कर रहा हूं क्योंकि यहां पर
मेरी कुछ सेंसिटिव इनेशन लीक हो जाएगी हो
गया बहुत सारी इनेशन आ गई आपकी
डन गाइस पता चल गया वहां पर इनेबल कंटेंट
किया और यहां पर आपको जो लinक्स मशीन थी
उसके ऊपर आपका डाटा एक्स फ़िल्टेट हो गया
जो डाटा आपको चाहिए था। अगर आपको देखना है
समझ में आया गाइज़? देखो आप यहां देखोगे
डेवलपर डेवलप डेवलपर टैब में अगर मै कोड
को देखोगे ये रहा वो पूरा मै कोड जो वहां
पर यहां पर एग्जीक्यूट हुआ और उसका आउटपुट
कहां पर देखने को मिला आपको? उसका आउटपुट
देखने को मिला है काली लinक्स के अंदर। ये
रहा। पहले से इस फाइल में कुछ नहीं था
क्योंकि यह फाइल हमने प्रेस क्रिएट की है।
यह फाइल हमने प्रेस क्रिएट की है। देखो
रजिस्ट्री चेक में हमें कुछ नहीं मिला।
उसके अलावा बाकी मैं नहीं शेयर करने वाला
क्योंकि इसमें सच में मेरी सेंसिटिव इनेशन
है। मेरी ईमेल्स हैं। मेरे अकाउंट नेम्स
हैं। बहुत कुछ है इसमें जो आपको शायद मे
बी
आई विल ट्राई एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर देखो। देखो
आईपी एड्रेस नेटवर्क इनेशन तक लेके आता
हूं मैं। लीक हो गया भाई। पता चल गया आपको
मेरी ईमेल तक लीक हो रही है इसमें। ये
देखो गीगाबेट नेटवर्क इस तरीके से बहुत
सारी इनेशन आ गई। तो ये थी हमारी टेक्निक
वन का प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेशन। तो अभी
हम आज पर आते हैं। आज हम क्या सीखने वाले
हैं? आज हमारा क्या है? आज हम ऐसी क्या
चीज सीखने वाले हैं जो सर आज से पहले नहीं
थी? देखिए आज हम
तीन चीजों पर काम करने वाले हैं। बेसिकली
हम अपनी स्टिल टेक्निक को बढ़ाने के लिए
तीन चीजों पर काम करने। सबसे पहला हम क्या
करने वाले हैं? सबसे पहले हम एक एंटीवीएम
चेक लगाएंगे। एंटी सेड बॉक्सिंग चेक
लगाएंगे। मतलब
मतलब जैसा आप सबको पता ही है कि जब भी कोई
सस्पिशियस फाइल किसी भी सिक्योरिटी टीम को
मिलती है, वह क्या करते हैं? एक सेंड
बॉक्स एनवायरमेंट है। उस फाइल को रन करते
हैं। तो हम उसका एक चेक लगाएंगे। ठीक है?
दूसरा हम क्या करने वाले हैं? दूसरा हम एक
कि जो मशीन है मशीन के ऊपर
Windows डिफेंडर रन कर रहा है नहीं कर रहा
है उसका एक चेक लगाएंगे। ठीक है? उसका एक
चेक लगाएंगे। बट जो Windows डिफेंडर है या
जो एडीआर की इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट करने के
लिए दिस डब्ल्यूएमआई का हम यूज करते हैं।
वह कई बार एक्यूरेट इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं देता।
बट थोड़ा बहुत ट्रस्ट किया जा सकता है।
जिसमें एंटीवायर्स की इंफॉर्मेशन तो
एक्यूरेट मिल सकती है बट आपको डिफेंडर जो
एडीआर्स है उनकी इंफॉर्मेशन एग्जैक्ट नहीं
मिलेगी क्योंकि एडीआर्स अपनी लोकेशन शिफ्ट
करते रहते हैं। तीसरी चीज हम क्या करने
वाले हैं? अभी हमने किस कनेक्शन का यूज
किया था?
अभी हमने किस चीज का यूज किया था? अभी
हमने नेटक लिसनर का यूज़ किया था। हमने
टीसीपी कनेक्शन जरूर यूज़ किया। लेकिन कौन
सा टीसीपी कनेक्शन यूज़ किया था हमने?
एचटीटीपी।
कौन सा टीसीपी कनेक्शन हमने यूज़ किया था?
हमने कौन सा कनेक्शन यूज़ किया? HTTP टीसीp
कनेक्शन।
अंडरस्टुड गाइज़? बट अभी हम HTTP को नहीं
यूज करने वाले। अभी हम HTTP कनेक्शन को
नहीं यूज करने वाले। तो हम किसको यूज करने
वाले हैं? हम यूज़ करने वाले हैं HTTPS।
हम यूज़ करने वाले हैं HTTPS। तो चलो वन
बाय वन। इसका भी कोड हम क्या करने वाले
हैं? अभी प्रोग्राम करने वाले हैं। आपके
सामने यूज करने वाले। तो हम फिर से
डेमोंस्ट्रेशन वाली फाइल को ओपन करेंगे।
गो टू डेवलपर टैब विजुअल बेसिक्स एंड अभी
इसमें मैंने क्या किया है कि इसमें मैं हर
स्टेप पर कुछ स्टेप बाय स्टेप स्टेप बाय
स्टेप चेकक्स लगाने वाला हूं। हर स्टेप पर
स्टेप बाय स्टेप मैं मैसेज बॉक्स लगाऊंगा
ताकि मुझे पहले ही पता चल जाए कि जो मेरी
स्क्रिप्ट है वो सही से काम कर रही है या
नहीं कर रही। जो मेरी स्क्रिप्ट है वो सही
से काम कर रही है या नहीं कर रही। यह
चेक्स मैं लगाने वाला हूं। उसके बाद इन
चेक्स को हम हटा देंगे। ठीक है? उसके बाद
हम डायरेक्टली रन करेंगे तो यह चेक्स हम
हटा देंगे। अभी हमें अगर आप ध्यान से
देखोगे कि जब मैंने इनेबल कंटेंट किया और
जब मैंने आपको स्टार्टिंग डे वन में जब
प्रैक्टिकल स्टार्ट किया था
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट का मैंने आपको यह बोला
था कि जब हम सोशल इंजीनियरिंग के लिए एक
परफेक्ट प्रीक्स्ट बनाते हैं। और हमने
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग के लिए परफेक्ट
प्रीक्स्ट बनाया था। हमारा पर्पस था इनेबल
कंटेंट हो। वो बॉक्स गायब हो उसके पीछे
क्या आ जाए? उसके पीछे हमारा
जो रिज्यूे था वह आ जाए। लेकिन उस कोड के
लिए हमने सही से काम नहीं किया है अभी तक।
क्योंकि वो कोड आप खुद भी कर लोगे। Google
पे सर्च करोगे, कहीं से सर्च करोगे वो कोड
आप खुद भी कर लोगे। उसकी चिंता नहीं है।
क्योंकि हमारा मेन काम क्या है कि हमें
डाटा एक्सिल्ट्रेट करवाना है। रिवर्स सेल
चाहिए या पे और ड्रॉप करवाना है। तीन चीज़
हमारा काम है सीखना। अगर आपको यह आती है
तो जो सोशल इंजीनियरिंग वाला काम है प्री
टेक्स्ट वाला आप कभी भी कर लोगे कभी भी
सीख लोगे तो वह चीज मैं अभी आपको नहीं
सिखा रहा तो अभी हम चलो इसको हम क्या कर
देते हैं अभी कंट्रोल ऑल और इसको कर देते
हैं ये डिलीट कंट्रोल ऑल और डिलीट किया
हमने तो चलो हम सबसे पहले किसके ऊपर चलते
हैं ये रहा तो सबसे पहले हम वही कर क्या
करने वाले हैं
ये रहा ठीक है सबसे पहले हम क्या करने
वाले हैं वही फिर से ओके ये हां भैया कुछ
ये रहा हमारा यहां तक हमने कॉपी कर लेते
हैं। यहां तक हम कॉपी कर लेते हैं।
कंट्रोल सी और यहां पर हमने पेस्ट किया।
पेस्ट कर दिया। सेम है रिपोर्ट डाटा एज
स्ट्रिंग एक ग्लोबल वेरिएबल एक ग्लोबल
वेरिएबल। उसके बाद डॉक्यूमेंट ओपन और इसके
बाद ये जो फंक्शन है ना कॉल अनहाइड
कैंडिडेट ये वाले को मैं हटा देता हूं।
बार मैं इसको यूज़ नहीं कर रहा। हमारा
पर्पस डायरेक्ट सिंपल सीधा है। उसके बाद
इसको भी हटा देता हूं। मैं इसको यूज़ नहीं
करने वाला कुछ। देन उसके बाद हमने एक
क्लॉग नाम का फंक्शन क्रिएट किया है।
जिसमें हम क्या करने वाले हैं? सारी
वैल्यू को स्टोर करने जिस फंक्शन की हेल्प
से हम रिपोर्ट डेटा नाम के एक वेरिएबल में
पूरी वैल्यू को स्टोर करने वाले हैं। यहां
तक सबको पता है। नेक्स्ट अब हम आते हैं
हमारा नेक्स्ट फेज पर। नेक्स्ट केस क्या
है? ये रहा हमारा मेन फंक्शन। तो फिर से
वही है। सारे वेरिएबल डिक्लेअर कर लेते
हैं। एक बार हम सारे वेरिएबल डिक्लेअर कर
लेते हैं। यहां पर ऐसे ठीक है? यहां पर हम
एक बार सारे वेरिएबल को क्या कर लेते हैं?
डिक्लेअ कर लेते हैं। कॉपी किया और यहां
पर आ जाते हैं। और यहां पर हम क्या कर
लेते हैं? सारे वेरिएबल्स को एक बार
डिक्लेअ कर लेते हैं। और यहां पर एक जो
एंड फंक्शन है इसको कॉपी कर लेता हूं। सो
दैट कि जो यहां पर आपको पता चल जाए कि ये
फंक्शन क्लोज हो गया। अदरवाइज क्या है?
यहां पर एरर देखने को मिलती। ये हो गया।
तो यहां तक सबको क्लियर है कि हमने
ऑब्जेक्ट सेल नाम का एक वेरिएबल क्रिएट
किया। नेटवर्क नाम का एक वेरिएबल क्रिएट
किया। wmआई सर्विस नाम का एक वेरिएबल
क्रिएट किया। कलेक्शन आइटम, ऑब्जेक्ट
आइटम, अटैकर आईपी, पावर सेल कमांड और वही
सेम रिप्लेस मेथड के लिए हमने एक वेरिएबल
क्रिएट कर लिया। यहां तक सबको पता है कुछ
भी नया नहीं है। सबसे पहले हम स्टेप वन पर
आते हैं। तो हम सबसे पहले स्टेप वन को डिज़
करते हैं। ठीक है? सबसे पहले हम क्या कर
रहे हैं? स्टेप वन। चलो, ये हमारा स्टेप
वन है। स्टेप वन में क्या है? हम क्या कर
रहे हैं? अलर्ट। ठीक है? हम स्टेप वन में
अलर्ट। एक मैसेज स्टेप वन। इनिशलाइजिंग
कॉम ऑब्जेक्ट एंड कनेक्टिंग टू
डब्ल्यूएमआई सर्विस वेबी इनफॉर्मेशन रेटिम
क्लासरूम डेमो यह रहा सबको पता है
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट सेल है डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट
नेटवर्क है और हमने क्या किया है गेट
ऑब्जेक्ट की हेल्प से डब्ल्यू जो एमआई के
साथ हम डायरेक्टली क्या कर रहे हैं एक
कनेक्शन एस्टैब्लिश कर लिया यहां तक सबको
क्लियर है तो ये चीज हमने प्रीवियस क्लास
में सीखी थी तो अभी हम नेक्स्ट स्टेप टू
में आ जाते हैं। हमारा स्टेप टू है। यह
हमारा स्टेप टू है एंटीबीएम चेक। यह हमारा
एक्चुअल में स्टेप टू एंटीवीएम चेक जो
सबसे पहला जो चैलेंज था हमारा यह है जो हम
अभी करने वाले हैं।
नेक्स्ट अभी एंटीवीएम चेक। ठीक है? तो अब
यह एंटीवीएम या सैंड बॉक्स डिटेक्शन लॉजिक
भी बोल सकते हो आप इसको। एंटीवीएम
वीएम या हम इसको बोल सकते हैं
चेंड बॉक्स
डिटेक्शन लॉजिक
सेंड बुक डिटेक्शन लॉजिक भी बोल सकते हैं।
बेसिकली क्या होता है जब भी कोई भी
सिक्योरिटी टीम किसी भी सस्पिशियस किसी भी
फाइल को सस्िशियस समझती है या कोई ईमेल
अटैचमेंट को एनालाइज करती है या किसी
सस्िशियस फाइल को एनालाइज करती है तो वो
क्या करती है? उस फाइल को एक आइसोलेटेड
वर्चुअल मशीन में या एक आइसोलेटेड
एनवायरमेंट में क्या करती है? ओपन करके
देखती है। तो हम हम क्या करना चाहते हैं?
हम इस लॉजिक में हमारा जो लॉजिक है इस
लॉजिक का पर्पस ही यही है कि क्या जो
हमारी फाइल है वो किसी आइसोलेटेड
एनवायरमेंट में तो ओपन नहीं हो रही। मतलब
किसी वीएमवेयर के ऊपर, किसी
अलग से कोई जो बॉक्स है मतलब वह आपको
फाइंड आउट करना पड़ेगा कि ऐसे कौन-कौन से
लॉजिक एनवायरमेंट है। ऐसेसे कौन-कौन सेंड
बॉक्स एनवायरमेंट जिसके अंदर एक
सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट उन फाइल्स को सेंड
बॉक्स कर सकता है। तो यहां पर हम तीन नाम
सर्च करेंगे वीएमवेयर वर्चुअल बॉक्स। आपको
सिखाने के लिए कि आप इस तरीके का चेक भी
लगा सकते हो अपने किसके अंदर? स्क्रिप्ट
के अंदर। तो बेसिकली मेरा मेन जो मोटो है,
जो मेन गोल है, आपको यह सिखाना कि आप अपनी
स्क्रिप्ट में स्टैंड बॉक्स डिटेक्शन के
लिए भी लॉजिक ऐड कर सकते हो। सो दैट कि आप
किसको क्या जो आपका जो सिक्योरिटी
एनालिस्ट है उसको बेवकूफ बना सको क्योंकि
उसको लगे कि नहीं यह फाइल तो जेन्युइन है।
और डिटेक्शन आप पहले ही कर लोगे ताकि आपका
जो एक्चुअल कोड रन ही ना करे। तो ये
डिटेक्शन हम यहां पर कर रहे हैं। तो सबसे
पहले हमने क्या किया? स्टेप टू
एग्जीक्यूटिंग एंटीवीएम या सैंडबोक
एनालिसिस वाया विन 32 कंप्यूटर सिस्टम्स।
क्योंकि यहां पर हम क्या किया? एक वेरिएबल
क्रिएट किया। एचवीएम नाम से एक बुलियन
वेरिएबल, डिटेक्ट मॉडल, डिटेक्ट
मैन्युफैक्चरर्स और एचवीएम इक्वल टू फॉल्स
कर दिया। तो सबसे पहले हम यहीं पर सेम वही
क्वरी यूज़ करेंगे। कौन सी? विन 32
कंप्यूटर सिस्टम्स का यूज़ करेंगे। उसके
बाद एक फॉर ईच ऑब्जेक्ट का यूज़ किया। यहां
पर हमने क्या किया? डिटेक्ट मॉडल वेरिएबल
के अंदर स्टोर किया। ऑब्जेक्ट डॉट मॉडल।
मतलब कि जो कंप्यूटरटर्स यूज़ हो रहा है
उसका हम मॉडल्स फाइंड आउट कर रहे हैं। अभी
यहां पर यह जो लॉजिक है यहां पर समझने की
बात यह है कि अगर ऑब्जेक्ट डॉट मॉडल्स है
और दूसरा क्या है? ऑब्जेक्ट डॉट
मैन्युफैक्चरर है। यहां पर दो चीज दो
चीजें हैं। मैन्युफैक्चर और मॉडल अगर मेरा
एसर का लैपटॉप फॉर एग्जांपल तो यहां पर
एसर का लैपटॉप आएगा। उसी का मैन्युफैक्चर
की डिटेल आएगी। अगर आप इसी चीज को
वीएमवेयर में चलाओगे तो वहां पर क्या
डिटेल आएगी? वीएमवेयर की डिटेल आएगी। ठीक
है? वहां पर वीएमवेयर की डिटेल आएगी।
वर्चुअल बॉक्स में चलाओगे वर्चुअल बॉक्स
की डिटेल आएगी। तो बेसिकली अगर आप कोई अगर
यहां पर आपको पता चल जाएगा स्टेप टू के
अंदर कि अगर आपकी जो स्क्रिप्ट है किसी
फिजिकल मशीन किसी फिजिकल कंप्यूटर पर रन
हुई है तो उस फिजिकल कंप्यूटरटर्स की
डिटेल यहां पर फैच होगी। अदरवाइज अगर वो
किसी सैंड बॉक्स एनवायरमेंट में रन हो रही
है तो सैंड बॉक्स एनवायरमेंट की डिटेल्स
यहां पर देखने को मिलेगी। उसके बाद हमने
क्या किया यहां पर ये
सीस एसटीआर एक फंक्शन होता है। इस फंक्शन
का काम क्या है कि ये कन्वर्ज़ करता है
स्ट्रिंग के अंदर। अब डेटा टाइप कोई भी हो
लेकिन ये स्ट्रिंग डेटा टाइप में उसको
वैल्यू को कन्वर्ट करता है। उसके बाद यहां
पर हम क्या कर रहे हैं? कंपैरिजन कर रहे
हैं। सबसे पहले वर्चुअल बॉक्स उस वैल्यू
जो वैल्यू यहां पर आ रही है ना आपकी किसके
किसकी? मॉडल की उस मॉडल की वैल्यू किसके
साथ कंपेयर कर रहे हैं? पहले वर्चुअल
बॉक्स के साथ। उसके बाद हम कंपेयर कर रहे
हैं वीएमवेयर के साथ। तीसरे हम क्या किसके
साथ कर रहे हैं? मैन्युफैक्चर यह रहा क्यू
क्या यह वाला मैन्युफैक्चर तो नहीं है।
उसके बाद अगर इनमें से कोई भी एक वैल्यू
मिलती है वर्चुअल बॉक्स वीएमवेयर या ये
थर्ड वन तो ये जो इज वीएम इक्वल टू ट्रू।
ये क्या हो जाएगा आपका? इज वीएम इक्व
ट्रू। और अगर
आपकी जो ये लॉजिक है अभी यहां पर हमने ऐसा
कोई लॉजिक लगाया नहीं। मैं जस्ट फॉर
प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेशन मैं आपको दिखाना
चाहता हूं। मैं इस लॉजिक के बेस पर मैं
क्या कर रहा हूं? एक मैसेज प्रप कर लूंगा
कि हां ये लॉजिक सही काम कर रहा है। इसने
क्या-क्या डिटेक्ट किया है। उसके लिए यहां
पर हमने क्या किया है? ये रहा एक मैसेज
बॉक्स यहां पर शो किया है। ये मैसेज
बॉक्स। वो सारी चीज डिटेक्ट करके बता
देगा। ठीक है? वो सारी चीजें वो डिटेक्ट
करके बता देगा। यह चिंता करने की जरूरत
नहीं है। लेकिन इन रियलिटी आप क्या कर
सकते हो कि इस चेक की हेल्प से जैसे ही यह
तीन चीजों में से कोई भी एक चीज डिटेक्ट
होती है आप सेम टाइप स्क्रिप्ट को यहीं पर
स्टॉप कर दोगे क्विट कर दोगे जिससे क्या
होगा कि जिसने इसको सेंड बॉक्स एनवायरमेंट
में रन किया है सस्पिशियस समझकर उसको
लगेगा कि ये एक जेन्युइन फाइल है। उसको
लगेगा एक ये जेन्युइन फाइल है। कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है। इसको अभी हम क्या करते हैं?
क्लाइंट के साथ शेयर कर देते हैं। अब इसने
तो डिटेक्ट कर लिया था कि वह वीएमवेयर के
अंदर रन कर रही है। तो इसने अपने कोड को
एग्जीक्यूट होने से रोक लिया। लेकिन जैसे
ही ये फिजिकल कंप्यूटर के ऊपर जाएगी फिर
से स्क्रिप्ट रन होगी। और जैसे स्क्रिप्ट
रन होगी तो ये फिर क्या हो जाएगा? फॉल्स
हो जाएगा आपकी कंडीशन। और जैसे ही कंडीशन
फॉल्स होगी तो आपका जो एक्चुअल पे लोड है
वह रन करेगा। तो इस तरीके से आप क्या कर
सकते हो? डिटेक्शन लगा सकते हो। तो यहां
तक हमने डिटेक्शन लगा लिया। यहां तक
क्लियर है सबको?
यहां तक सबको क्लियर है।
यहां तक सबको क्लियर है? गुड। तो चलो फिर
हम नेक्स्ट बढ़ते हैं।
चलो फिर हम नेक्स्ट बढ़ते हैं।
एक गाइज मुझे जस्ट गिव मी वन 30 सेकंड का
टाइम दे दिया प्लीज। मुझे एक कॉल आ रहा
है।
इट्स ओके तो अभी हम चलते हैं हमारे सेकंड
कोड के ऊपर। तो सेकंड स्टेप हमारा क्या
है? ये रहा। अभी हम डेटा एक्सिल्ट्रेशन के
लिए कुछ ये कोड लिख लेते हैं। ये कोड आपको
समझ में आ जाएगा। अगर नहीं समझ में आएगा
मैं आपको बता देता हूं। देखो ये क्या है?
लॉग क्या है? डेटा एक्सिल्ट्रेशन स्टोरेज
के लिए log क्या है? log आपका फंक्शन है।
अलग से कोई कोड नहीं दे रहा। यहां पर हमने
एक फंक्शन क्रिएट किया था log नाम का। यह
वही फंक्शन है। इस फंक्शन के अंदर हम क्या
कर रहे हैं? एक टेक्स्ट वैल्यू पास कर रहा
हूं जो हम फैच कर रहे हैं। तो यहीं पर वो
वही वैल्यू पास हो रही है। यहीं पर वही
वैल्यू यहां पर पास हो रही है। चलो फिर
नेक्स्ट हमारा स्टेप थ्री है। सेम ये
प्रीवियस वाला है। स्टेप थ्री एंड फोर
स्टेप थ्री यहां पर ये हो गया। कंट्रोल सी
ये हमारा स्टेप थ्री है। तो चलो कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है।
ये रहा स्टेप थ्री। ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की
डिटेल्स हम क्या कर रहे हैं? यहां पर
फाइंड आउट कर रहे हैं। स्टेप थ्री में हम
क्या कर रहे हैं? ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की
डिटेल्स फाइंड आउट कर रहे हैं। अभी उसके
बाद हम क्या कर रहे हैं? एक और स्टेप फोर
हमारा क्या है? स्टेप फोर में हम फाइंड
आउट कर रहे हैं किसकी? ये रही। इसकी
डिटेल हम फाइंड आउट कर रहे हैं हमारे
एंटीवायरस की डिटेल। अब यहां पर हम फाइंड
आउट कर रहे हैं एंटीवायरस की डिटेल।
यहां पर हम फाइंड आउट कर रहे हैं
एंटीवायरस की डिटेल।
ये रहा। यहां पर सिक्योरिटी प्रोडक्ट्स की
डिटेल्स यहां पर फाइंड आउट कर रहे हैं।
ठीक है? हमारा जो मेन टारगेट है यह फाइंड
आउट करना है कि जो आपकी मशीन है उसके अंदर
एंटीवायरस इंस्टॉल है या नहीं है। एडीआर
के रिलेटेड ये क्या है कि सही इनेशन नहीं
डिटेक्ट करता। और उसके लिए हम किसका यूज़
करते हैं? अब की बार देखो ध्यान से देखोगे
ना यहां सबसे पहले यह मैसेज बॉक्स प्र
किया है। उसके बाद लॉग ऑन रिज्यूम यह रहा।
देन यह रहा। अब की बार इसके लिए हम यूज़
करते हैं रूट सिक्योरिटी सेंटर टू। रूट
सिक्योरिटी सेंटर टू।
रूट सिक्योरिटी सेंटर टू ओके रूट
सिक्योरिटी सेंटर टू यह वो लोकेशन जहां से
हम डाटा फैच कर रहे हैं। किसकी हेल्प से?
कॉम ऑब्जेक्ट की हेल्प से गेट ऑब्जेक्ट का
हमने एक ऑब्जेक्ट किया और wmआई का हम यूज़
कर रहे हैं उसके अंदर। उसके बाद क्यूरी की
एंटीवायरस प्रोडक्ट और यहां पे देखो
एंटीवायरस का नेम फाइंड आउट कर रहे हैं।
उसके बाद स्टेटस कोड हम उसका फाइंड आउट कर
रहे हैं। रनिंग है नॉट रनिंग है। उसके बाद
हम क्या कर रहे हैं? एवी लिस्ट एक इसके
अंदर हम स्टोर कर रहे हैं, डिस्प्ले कर
रहे हैं स्टेटस को। कहां पर यूज़ करेंगे?
हम अपने प्र में यूज़ करेंगे। उसके बाद हम
यह भी चेक कर रहे हैं कि इफ अगर यह एंप्टी
है हमें कोई भी वैल्यू नहीं मिलती है तो
इसका मतलब क्या है कि यहां पर दो कारण हो
सकते हैं। पहला कारण हो सकता है कि कोई
थर्ड पार्टी एंटीवायरस रजिस्टर हुआ है जो
जिसकी कोई डिटेल नहीं है या फिर क्या है
कि इसके अगेंस्ट एक एक्सेस रिस्ट्रिक्टेड
है। मतलब वो वैल्यू हम फाइंड आउट नहीं कर
पाए हैं। इसके दो ही कारण हो सकते हैं। तो
अब नेक्स्ट स्टेप फाइव में हम क्या करते
हैं? यह रहा। पर्सिस्टेंस चेक के लिए हम
यह रजिस्ट्री चेक वाला एक मेथड यूज करने
वाले हैं। चलो फिर इसको भी कंट्रोल सी और
यहां पर पेस्ट कर देते हैं। किसी को कोड
ऐसा तो नहीं लग रहा कि सर ये कोड बहुत
ज्यादा बोरिंग लग रहा है कि हमें समझ में
नहीं आ रहा सर। ऐसा तो नहीं यहां पर
असिस्टेंट चेक करने हम देखो रजिस्ट्री चेक
कर रहे हैं। रजिस्ट्री ऐसे चेक कर सकते
हैं। ये रहा। देखो ये जो स्टेप है ना इसको
मैं अभी समझाऊं भी या ना आपको नहीं समझ
में आएगा। बिकॉज़ इसके लिए आपको अच्छी खासी
Windows की नॉलेज होनी चाहिए। आपको अच्छी
अच्छी खासी चीजों के बारे में पता होना
चाहिए। इसलिए मैं क्या है कुछ चीजें ऐसी
हैं जिनको मैं यहां पर कट कॉपी पेस्ट कर
रहा हूं। मैं हर एक लाइन बाय लाइन कोड लिख
भी सकता था। बट इस कोड को लाइन बाय लाइन
समझाऊंगा। तो ये सही टाइम नहीं है आपको
समझाने का। बिकॉज़ उसके लिए आपको ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम की काफी अच्छी गहरी डिटेल्स नॉलेज
होनी चाहिए। तभी आपको मजा आएगा ये चीजों
चीजों के लिए। इसलिए मैं यहां पर कट कॉपी
पेस्ट कर रहा हूं। तो ऐसा प्लीज कोशिश मत
कीजिए कि समझिए कि सर आप ये जस्ट बता रहे
हो क्योंकि कुछ मैंने आपको पहले बताया था
कि वीडियो के स्टार्टिंग में कि आज का जो
टॉपिक है आज का जो लेक्चर्स है उसमें ऐसी
चीजें हैं जो बहुत सारी आपके लिए आउट ऑफ
माइंड रहेंग जो आपको शायद समझ में नहीं आए
क्योंकि यह सही समय नहीं है आपको समझाने
का और आपके समझने के लिए क्योंकि आप बेसिक
सीखने आए हो पहले आपका बेसिक क्लियर होगा
तब आपको जब सही समय होगा ना जब आप मालवेयर
डेवलपमेंट एक्सप्लोर डेवलपमेंट सीखोगे तब
ये सही समय होता है सारी चीजें सीखने का।
नेक्स्ट अभी ये फिर हम नेटवर्क को यूजर्स
की इनेशन फाइंड आउट करते हैं। इससे रहा तो
यहां तक हमने क्या कर लिया? ये स्क्रिप्ट
को फाइंड आउट कर लिया। कंट्रोल C इसको भी
हम यहां पे यूज़ कर लेते हैं। ये रहा। तो
ये हमारा नेटवर्क्स और यूज़र्स फाइंड आउट
करने के लिए हमने यहां पर यह कोड लिख
लिया। लोग हो गया। उसके बाद यह लोकल
यूज़र्स अकाउंट के लिए हो गया। यहां तक
हमारा क्या हो गया? जो रिकॉन पार्ट था
कंप्लीट हो गया। यहां तक हमारा रिकॉन
पार्ट कंप्लीट हो चुका है। यहां तक हम
रिकॉन कंप्लीट कर लिया। अभी हमें क्या
करना है? हमें अपनी काली लinक्स के साथ भी
क्या करना है? नेटवर्क कनेक्शन बनाना है।
काली लinक्स के साथ नेटवर्क कनेक्शन बनाना
है। वो कैसे बना सकते हैं हम? स्टेप सेवन।
और ये हमारी स्क्रिप्ट एंड हो जाएगी यहां
पर कंप्लीट। तो चलो इतना ही कोड है हमारा।
नेक्स्ट ये रहा। स्टेप सेवन। स्टेप सेवन
में हम क्या करेंगे कि हम एचtटीपीएस
कनेक्शन का यूज़ करने वाले हैं। स्टेप सेवन
में हम एचटीटीपीएस कनेक्शन का यूज़ करने
वाले हैं। किसके लिए? डेटा एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन
के लिए। और डेटा को हम किस में अंदर फैच
करने वाले हैं? हम बेस 64 में डेटा को
एक्सिल्ट्रेट करेंगे। तो ये देखो एक प्र्ट
आएगा इनकोडिंग डेटा टू बेस 64 एंड
एक्सिल्ट्रेटिंग ओवर एचटीटीपीएस पोर्ट
नंबर 443। उसके बाद यहां पर हम अटैकर आईपी
में क्या देंगे?
ठीक है? उसके बाद ये सेम है सिंगल कोड को
डबल सिंगल कोड में कन्वर्ट करना। उसके बाद
ये आपका वो कोड है जो यहां पर एग्जीक्यूट
हो रहा है। सबसे पहले आप ये देखोगे कोड
में यहां पर तो ये आपका वो कोड है।
ठीक है? तो इससे पहले क्या हो रहा था कि
इससे पहले जो हम डाटा भेज रहे थे वह प्लेन
टेक्स्ट में भेज रहे थे http कनेक्शन के
थ्रू पोर्ट नंबर 80 पर जिसको बहुत ही
आसानी से डिटेक्ट किया जा सकता है। लेकिन
अब की बार हमने क्या किया है? अभी हम यूज़
करने वाले हैं एक्चुअल में एचटीटीपीएस
कनेक्शन का पोर्ट नंबर 443 का और उसके लिए
हम एक Python स्क्रिप्ट यूज़ करेंगे जो
क्या करेगी? एक सर्वर को रन करेगी। उस
सर्वर पे एक सर्टिफिकेट होगा। उस सर्वर पे
एक सर्टिफिकेट होगा क्योंकि एचटीटीपीएस
कनेक्शन के लिए आपको क्या चाहिए? एसएसएल
सर्टिफिकेट चाहिए। और एक डमी एसएस
सर्टिफिकेट उस सर्वर पे क्फ़िगर किया
जाएगा और यहां पर उस सर्टिफिकेट को चेक भी
नहीं किया जाएगा। कैसे? यह आपको पता है।
टेक्स्ट के अंदर वो डेटा स्टोर कर लिया।
उसके बाद यह भी आपको पता है कि यहां पर
हमने यूटीएफ 8 के अंदर उसको कन्वर्ट कर
लिया बाइट के अंदर। उसके बाद बाइट को हमने
क्या किया? बेस 64 में इनकोड कर दिया।
यहां पर बेस 64 में इनकोड कर दिया। इसकी
हेल्प से कन्वर्ट डबल कॉलन टू बेस 64
स्ट्रिंग। उसके बाद बाइट को हमने बेस 64
में कन्वर्ट कर दिया क्योंकि हमें
ट्रांसफर करना है। उसके बाद हमने एक और
एक्शन परफॉर्म किया। देन यहां पर यह रहा
सिस्टम नेट डॉट सर्विस पॉइंट मैनेजर। यह
क्या करता है? सिस्टम नेट डॉट सर्विस
पॉइंट मैनेजर यहां पर क्या करता है कि यह
यहां पर यह एक डॉट नेट फ्रेमवर्क की क्लास
है। यह आपकी डॉट नेटवर्क फ्रेमवर्क की
क्लास है। यहां पर क्या होता है कि जब भी
हम अ https
हैंड चेक करते हैं। जब भी हम https के
थ्रू हैंड चेक करते हैं तो हमें एक एसएसएल
सर्टिफिकेट दिखाना होता है। एक एसएल
सर्टिफिकेट दिखाना होता है कनेक्शन के लिए
कि हां भाई मेरे पास एक सर्टिफिकेट है।
आपके साथ कनेक्शन बनाना है। जब वो
सर्टिफिकेट दिखाया जाता है तो Windows में
एक डॉट नेट
क्या है? Windows में एक डॉट नेट के लिए
एक डॉट नेट फ्रेमवर्क का फंक्शन होता है।
कौन सा फंक्शन होता है? यह फंक्शन होता है
जो सर्टिफिकेट को चेक करता है। सर्विस
सर्टिफिकेट वैलिडेशन कॉल बैक। यह वो
फंक्शन है Windows में जो चेक करता है।
Windows में जो चेक करता है कि आपके पास
एक वैलिड सर्टिफिकेट है या नहीं है। कौन
सा सर्टिफिकेट? एसएसएल सर्टिफिकेट और हमने
इसकी वैल्यू को क्या कर दिया? ट्रू कर
दिया। हमने इसकी वैल्यू को ट्रू कर दिया।
यह वैल्यू कब रिटर्न होती है ट्रू? जब
वो सर्टिफिकेट चेक हो जाए। चेक होने के
बाद संतुष्टि मिल जाए कि वो सर्टिफिकेट
वैलिड है। आप उसको यूज़ कर सकते हो।
कनेक्शन बना सकते हो। उसके बाद वो ट्रू
वैल्यू रिटर्न होती है। हमने यहां पर क्या
बोला कि मैं आपको कुछ चेक नहीं करना। मुझे
कोई फर्क नहीं पड़ता सर्टिफिकेट किसका है।
सर्टिफिकेट एक्सपायर हुआ या नहीं हुआ। आप
जस्ट एक काम करो कनेक्शन को अलव करो। जस्ट
एक काम करो। आप कनेक्शन को अलव करो। तो
यहां पर यह क्या कर रहा है? सबसे
इंपॉर्टेंट है आप इसको डायरेक्टली कभी भी
यूज़ करो। डायरेक्टली यूज़ करो। ऐसे ऐसे यूज़
कर सकते हो। क्योंकि यह क्या बोल रहा है?
यह फोर्स कर रहा है कि भैया आपको
सर्टिफिकेट कोई एक्सपायर हो या ना हो या
सर्टिफिकेट किसका है? किसका नहीं है? मेरी
तरफ से ट्रू है। आपको कनेक्शन बनाना ही
है। आप कनेक्शन
अलाउड है आपको कनेक्शन। उसके बाद हमने
यहां पर क्या किया? इनवोक रिक्वेस्ट मेथड
का यूज़ किया। एचटीटीपीएस हमारा आईपी
एड्रेस पोर्ट नंबर 443 अपलोड नाम के
फोल्डर पर हम जाकर क्या करेंगे? पोस्ट
मेथड का यूज करते हुए उस डाटा को अपलोड कर
दें। उसके बाद यहां पर हमने इसको रन कर
दिया टिल मोड में। उसके बाद इसको क्लीन कर
दिया। तो यहां तक किसी को कोई डाउट है तो
बता दीजिए। अगर कोई डाउट नहीं है तो भी
बता दीजिए। इसको अब अभी हम डमी स्टार्ट
करके देखेंगे ताकि मुझे यह पता चल जाए कि
यहां पर कोई एरर तो नहीं आ रही। उसके बाद
हम उसके साथ स्टार्ट करेंगे।
ओके? द स्टार्ट करके देखें।
आर यू गाइस रेडी? आप सब लोग रेडी है? तो
चलिए मैं इसको क्या करता हूं? रन करके
देखता हूं। यहां पे करता हूं मैं रन। करूं
रन? मैंने किया रन।
डिसेबल प्लीज रेफर। ओके ये डिसेबल है।
ओके। तो ये डिसेबल कैसे यहां पर देखो यहां
पर देखोगे यहां पर मैंने इनेबल नहीं किया।
मैंने इनेबल कंटेंट कर दिया। देखो जैसे
इनेबल कंटेंट किया रेटिम क्लासरूम डेमो
स्टेप वन इनिशलाइजिंग कॉम ऑब्जेक्ट एंड
कनेक्टिंग टू डब्ल्यूएमआई सर्विस पहला
स्टेप एग्जीक्यूट हो गया
क्लिक करूं स्टेप वन एग्जीक्यूट हो गया
स्टेप वन सही से काम कर रहा है एवरीवन
देखो ध्यान से उसके बाद जैसे मैंने ओके
किया स्टेप टू भी एग्जीक्यूट हो गया देखो
एग्जीक्यूटिंग एंटीवीएम सेंड बुक एनालिसिस
वाया विन 32 कंप्यूटर सिस्टम्स स्टेप टू
भी एग्जीक्यूट हो गया। इसका रिजल्ट देखते
हैं। ये क्या बोल रहा है? देखो एंटीवीएम
डिटेक्शन रिजल्ट
एस सर मॉडल कौन सा है? प्रेडिक्टर पी 1671
क्या ये वर्चुअल मशीन है? फॉल्स है।
क्योंकि ये वर्चुअल मशीन नहीं है। इसलिए
यहां पर क्या है? फॉल्स आ गया। डिटेक्ट
किया। यह सैंड बॉक्स एनवायरमेंट नहीं है।
डिटेक्ट हुआ। सैंड बॉक्स एनवायरमेंट नहीं
है।
उसके बाद मैंने ओके किया।
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की डिटेल फैच की स्टेप
थ्री उसके बाद यह चेक किया क्यूरिंग
सिक्योरिटी प्रोडक्ट कौन सा Windows
डिफेंडर वगैरह के ये देखो Windows डिफेंडर
और तीसरा एंटीवायरस कौन सा दो चीज मिली
इसने Windows डिफेंडर और एवेस्ट एंटीवायरस
में हमें दो एंटीवायर थे। उन दोनों डिटेल
मिल गई कि मैं एक एंटीवायरस भी यूज़ कर रहा
हूं। Windows डिफेंडर का भी यूज़ कर रहा
हूं। और उनका स्टेटस रनिंग है।
मिल गई है डिटेल भी
यह डिटेल भी मिल गई ना
मिल गई उसके बाद क्लिक करते हैं नेक्स्ट
ये रहा इनमरेटिंग रजिस्ट्री की ओके अभी ये
मेरे को एरर दिखा दो भाई इतना ही है ओके
कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं मैंने बंद कर दिया
क्योंकि इसने डिटेक्ट कर लिया मेरे में
रियल टाइम प्रोटेक्शन चल रहा है तो फॉर
योर काइंड इंफॉर्मेशन रियल टाइम डिटेक्शन
बायपास नहीं कर पाएगा क्योंकि मैंने आपको
उस लेवल का नहीं बताया कि आप रियल टाइम
डिटेक्शन को बाईपास कर पाओ। बट मैंने आपको
वो जरूर बता दिया कि आप धीरे-धीरे कैसे
आगे बढ़ सकते हो। यह तो शुरुआत थी और भी
कुछ कर सकते हो। रियल डेट डिडक्शन बास
बाईपास करना इतना आसान नहीं है। इतने आसान
जल्दी नहीं कर पाओगे। कर सकते हो। बट आज
यहां पे YouTube की क्लासेस से या इनसे
नहीं कर पाओगे। तो यह थी मेरी स्क्रिप्ट।
अभी मैं स्क्रिप्ट को कहां पे ले चलूंगा?
Windows के ऊपर। तो चलो स्क्रिप्ट को हम
कॉपी करते हैं भैया क्योंकि इसने बंद किया
है इसको और इसको यहां से मैं इसको क्लोज
तो पहले इसको ऑन करता हूं।
हां। तो मैंने आपको क्या बताया था?
डिटेक्शन लेवल इतना नहीं बताया मैंने कि
आप किसी भी एंटीवायसन को बायपास कर पाओ।
नो।
ठीक है। अभी मैं इसको क्लोज करता हूं।
इसको मैं क्लोज करता हूं। इसको मैं ऑन
करता हूं। यह रहा। यहां पर मैं पेस्ट
करूंगा डेमो को
माय Windows 10 के ऊपर।
आपको बस बता रहा था कि ऐसेसे आप स्टेप बाय
स्टेप आगे बढ़ सकते हो। मैंने सच देखो मैं
झूठ नहीं बोल रहा आपको। मैं आपको वो बता
रहा हूं कि मैंने वो चीज नहीं सिखाया कि
आप हर चीज बाईपास कर सकते हो। नहीं तो मैं
इसको क्या करता हूं अभी?
ये रहा।
इसको मैं क्लोज करता हूं। इसको मैं क्लोज
करता हूं। इसको मैं डिलीट करता हूं। और
चलो भैया बाय बाय। यहां से स्क्रिप्ट
उठाएंगे।
लो
आ जाओ भाई।
व्हाट हैपन?
कोई बात नहीं। हम डॉक्यूमेंट्स डालेंगे
भैया। हमारी क्या दिक्कत है?
तब तो आओगे। यह रहा। यहां पर हमने पटक
दिया। इसको उठा उठा के रिफ्रेश कर देते
हैं। हो गया। उसके बाद हमें क्या करना है?
जिस मैं Python स्क्रिप्ट की बात कर रहा
था। ये है वो Python स्क्रिप्ट। ठीक है?
यहां पे देखते हैं। मैं आपको दिखाता हूं।
वो पython स्क्रिप्ट कौन सी है? यहां पे
दिखाऊंगा मैं आपको।
एलएस ये है। मेरे पास Python स्क्रिप्ट है
व्हिच इज़ लिसनर डॉटpi। मैं आपको नैनो करके
दिखा देता हूं। नैनो
लिसनर डॉट पाई। यह वह Python स्क्रिप्ट है
जिसके अंदर मैंने प्लस का यूज किया है।
उसके बाद मैंने बेस 64 को डिकोड किया है।
डिकोड करने के बाद मैं रियल टाइम में उस
ट्रैफिक को क्या कर रहा हूं? कैप्चर कर
रहा हूं। यह वो Python स्क्रिप्ट है जिसका
मैं यूज़ करने वाला हूं डाटा को रिसीव करने
के लिए वाया HTTPS कनेक्शन। सबको दिखाई दे
रहा है?
चलो एक मिनट है। एक बार देख लो। जिसको
Python की नॉलेज है वह समझ जाएगा। जिसको
Python की नॉलेज नहीं है, वह प्लीज उसको
सीखना पड़ेगा।
यहां पर किस-किस को पथन आता है?
क्योंकि मैंने इसको इसलिए एक्सप्लेन नहीं
किया जिसको पाइthन नहीं आती वो फायदा नहीं
है।
इसलिए इतना समझो कि आप ऐसा कर सकते हो।
चलो इसको मैं अभी कर देता हूं क्लोज।
कंट्रोल एक्स हो गया। मैं इसको क्या करता
हूं? अभी रन कर देता हूं। इसको मैं क्या
करता हूं? रन करूंगा। इसको रन कैसे करूंगा
मैं?
Python 3
Python 3 बोला था। क्या कर रहा है भाई?
यह प्रॉब्लम है भैया।
कोई इस प्रॉब्लम के बारे में थोड़ा सा
जानता है ये प्रॉब्लम क्या है? मुझे मैं
रॉल्व नहीं कर पा रहा इसको। python 3
listनer डॉट पाई और हिट एंटर कर दिया
मैंने।
चलो हमारी
सर्वर स्टार्ट हो गया। स्टार्टिंग
एचtटीपीएस लिसन पोर्ट नंबर 443 यह रहा।
ओके
यह हमारा IPपी एड्रेस है 161 ये वाला। और
सेम आईपी एड्रेस क्या हमने उसमें दिया है?
ध्यान से देखेंगे तो उसी में सेम IPपी
एड्रेस हमने दिया था। इफ यू रिमेंबर अगर
आपको याद होगा तो ओपन करें।
ओपन भी कर लिया।
लो इनेबल कंटेंट था पहले से ही। स्टेप वन
आ गया।
स्टेप वन आ गया। एक काम करता हूं मैं इसको
अलग निकाल सकता हूं कहीं पर।
एक काम करता हूं मैं इसको अगर मैं
हां इसको
ऐसा ऑप्शन है कि मैं इनको अलग-अलग दिखा
दूं आपको।
ऐसा कोई ऑप्शन नहीं है। वेट वेट हां हो
गया हो गया हो गया।
अभी तक यह है। इसको भी शॉर्ट फॉर्म में कर
देते हैं। यह रहा शॉर्ट।
परफेक्ट।
इतना करता हूं मैं इसको।
इसको इतना करता हूं।
ओके। करें।
स्टार्ट करें। चलो
ओके
हो गया। एग्जीक्यूटिंग एंटीवा सो करके फिर
से मैं क्लिक करता हूं। फिर से क्लिक
किया। अभी देखो क्या आया इसमें
डिटेक्टेड मैन्युफैक्चर वीएमवेयर मॉडल
वीएमवेयर
मतलब इज वर्चुअल मशीन ट्रू है। ये वर्चुअल
मशीन है। हमें यहां पर स्क्रिप्ट को क्या
कर देना चाहिए था? क्विट कर देना चाहिए
था।
लेकिन हम क्विट नहीं कर रहे क्योंकि हमें
प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेशन देखना है। ओके
किया ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम इनफ फाइंड आउट की।
ये किया ओके ओके ओके
ओके
व्हाट हैपन?
आई थिंक इज देयर एनी प्रॉब्लम वि
स्क्रिप्ट? हम एक ओपन करते हैं इसको।
ओके
एंड
ओके बिल्कुल क्लीन हो गया तो तो एक काम
करते हैं मैं इसको बंद कर देता हूं एक बार
थोड़ा सा इशू हुआ कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं
अभी इसको मैं क्लोज करता हूं।
[संगीत]
इसमें डिफेंडर भी ऑन नहीं है। प्रॉब्लम
क्या है?
हम एक काम करते हैं। एक और स्क्रिप्ट
क्रिएट करते हैं। एक फाइल क्रिएट करते हैं
यहां पर वर्ड के नाम से। ठीक है? और
उसके अंदर सारी स्क्रिप्ट को कॉपी कर
देंगे।
डेमो वाला डेट कोड कहीं चला तो नहीं गया।
और हमारा आईपी एड्रेस देखना इसमें कहां
गया?
IP एड्रेस तो सही है। कंट्रोल ऑल कंट्रोल
सी और इसके बाद हम क्या करने वाले हैं?
चलो इसको रन करके देखेंगे। ऐसे ही
ओके ओके यहां पर देखते हैं हम।
नो Microsoft Office डॉक्यूमेंट
ओके।
[संगीत]
क्योंकि इसने एक बार कर लिया तो हम एक काम
कर लेते हैं। इसको भी डिलीट करते हैं।
इसको भी डिलीट करते हैं। और इसके बाद हम
क्या करने वाले हैं? एक नया डॉक्यूमेंट
क्रिएट करेंगे।
नो microsoft डॉक्यूमेंट
वि
इसको हम क्या करने वाले? सेव एज
यह रहा सेव
कर देंगे। यह रहा डेवलपर वीवीए
दिस डॉक्यूमेंट्स यहां पर हम पेस्ट कर
देंगे।
ये रहा हमारा 192 168 119
इज इट ओके? 13 पहले मैं इसको रन करके देख
लेता हूं। तो रन किया।
ओके ओके ओके [संगीत]
ओके
देखो एग्जीक्यूट हो गया उस साइड।
उस साइड एग्जीक्यूट हो गया। ध्यान से
देखोगे। ये रहा सेम वैल्यू इधर आ गई। ऐसे
देखो ये था ना? एग्जीक्यूट हुआ। हो गया
क्योंकि वो पिछली बार उसने एक बार डिटेक्ट
कर लिया उसको हमें डिलीट करके दोबारा वो
करना पड़ेगा।
हो गया। अगर मैं इसको क्लोज करता हूं।
मैं सेव किया। सेव हो गया। एंड वि वन आई
नीड।
ठीक है।
उसके बाद फिर से मैं डबल क्लिक किया।
और इसमें ऐसा कुछ नहीं है।
इसमें है
ओके। इसमें ऐसा कुछ नहीं है। इसको हम
क्लोज करते हैं।
इसमें होगा ये रहा इनेबल कंटेंट करूं।
इनेबल कंटेंट ओके ओके ओके ओके ओके ओके ओके
एंड ये इसने डिटेक्ट कर रहा है। क्यों?
ओके इसको मैं क्या करता हूं? होगी। यह
डिटेक्ट कर लिया इसने। तो इसका भी हमें
सोलशन निकालना पड़ेगा। वो सोलशन हमें
ढूंढना पड़ेगा। तो
इसने सेम टाइम बंद कर दिया। इसका कारण
क्या है ना इसकी सेटिंग
किसकी सेटिंग? मैक की सेटिंग क्योंकि हमने
डायरेक्टली यहां ऑन किया होगा। माइक्रो की
सेटिंग पे इतना ध्यान नहीं दिया तो वो
प्रॉब्लम है। क्योंकि इसमें मैंने जो
स्टार्टिंग में जो सेटिंग थी ना वो यहां
पर यूज़ नहीं की हुई। बाकी आप लोग एक काम
करना आप लोगों के लिए टास्क है यह डिटेक्ट
क्यों कर रहा है यह फाइंड आउट करके आप लोग
हमारे tlegram ग्रुप में बताओगे tlegram
में ग्रुप में बताओगे
बड़ा कुछ सीखने को मिला आप लोगों रुको
बता दीजिए
विंडोज एंटीवायरस के ऊपर बायपास के ऊपर
में भाई अभी तो मेरे पास सच में समय नहीं
है आई विल प्लान बट फ्री वाली नहीं होगी
पेड हो सकती है आई विल ट्राई कि कुछ मैं
निकाल पाऊं ओके
तो बाकी किसी को कोई डाउट रिलेटेड टू द
क्लास किसी को कुछ पूछना है
मुझे एक चीज बताओ जो हमारी सीरीज चलती है
अ साइबर वारफेयर वाली जिसका एपिसोड एक ही
आया है दो मैं लेकर नहीं आया किसी कारण ये
था कि हमारा जो फिलहाल लोगों को मैं देखना
चाहता कि लोग कितने इंटरेस्टेड है नॉट
इंटरेस्टेड कैसी है उसका रिव्यु चाहिए
मुझे आप लोगों से
कुछ आप लोगों के लिए यूज़फुल है या नहीं है
प्लीज मुझे उसका रिवु चाहिए आप लोगों से
तो क्या कोई एक दो पांच लोग मेरे को उसका
रिव्यु दे सकते हो कि सर बेनिफिशियल नहीं
होगी तो उसको मत कंटिन्यू कीजिए सर
बेनिफिशियल हो सकती है बिकॉज
वह एक एपिसोड वन था। बहुत कुछ है जो आपके
रियल वर्ल्ड अटैक से जुड़ा हुआ है। चाहे
आपकी इलेक्शन की हैकिंग हो, चाहे आपके
स्टेट स्पों्सर्ड अटैक की बात हो, नेशन
स्टेट अटैक की बात हो, एक देश की दूसरे
देश ने उसको अपने आपको अपने साइबर
कैपेबिलिटी को कैसे डेवलप किया।
यह सारी चीजें उसमें इंक्लूड है जो हम कर
सकते हैं। खास करके शौक के लिए तो बहुत
बेनिफिशियल है। यह सबके लिए बेनिफिशियल
है। तो प्लीज मुझे आप लोगों का एक रिव्यु
चाहिए क्योंकि
कुछ दिन में ही उसका एपिसोड टू आने वाला
है।
मुझे आप लोगों से जेन्युइन रिवो चाहिए।
लोग क्या सोचते हैं वो बाद में सोच लूंगा
मैं। आप लोग जब तक जेन्युइन रिव्यु नहीं
देगा मुझे कैसे पता चलेगा?
बिल्कुल देखो अप टू डेट तो क्या है कि
आपको जब यह पता ही नहीं होगा कि साइबर
अटैक होते क्या है? कैसे होते हैं? और जब
आप किसी कंपनी में काम कर रहे हो तो मैं
किस चीज के बारे में मेरी वैल्यू क्या है?
मैं किस चीज को प्रोटेक्ट कर रहा हूं?
क्योंकि आपको अपनी वैल्यू ही नहीं पता
होगा तो आप वो काम कैसे करोगे? आई एम
राइट? वो चीजें हैं।
तो चलिए फिर आज का सेशन इतना ही था। अगर
आप लोगों के कोई भी डाउट है तो प्लीज
हमारे tlegram ग्रुप में पूछ सकते हो।
कमेंट सेक्शन में पूछ सकते हो। अगेन मैं
आप लोगों से एक और रिक्वेस्ट करता हूं कि
प्लीज
क्लास को आप लोग देखते हो। देखने के बाद
एक बार उसको लाइक भी कर दीजिए और कमेंट भी
कर दीजिए ताकि लोगों को भी पता चले सच में
कंटेंट अच्छा है। उसमें सच में कंटेंट
अच्छा है। और जो नेक्स्ट क्लास होगी
नेक्स्ट क्लास में हम
अपने एमएसएफ पेलोड को इंटीग्रेट करना
सीखेंगे और रिवर्स सेल लेना स्टार्ट
करेंगे। ओके? स्टील इतना मेंटेन नहीं
करेंगे। पहले मुझे यह सिखाना है कि हम
कैसे पेलोड डेवलपमेंट कर सकते हैं। उसके
बाद हम देख लेंगे स्किल्स मेंटेन करने के
लिए। बुक्स होंगी तो मैं बुक्स आपको
प्रोवाइड कर दूंगा जो आपके लिए बहुत
बेनिफिशियल होंगी बाकी सारी चीजें। तो
चलिए फिर अगर आप लोगों का कोई भी डाउट
नहीं है तो सेशन को यहीं पर एंड करते हैं
और मिलते हैं फिर नेक्स्ट सेशन में। सी यू
गाइस बाय बाय। गुड नाइट एवरीवन।